SO MANY OF US ARE WORRIED ABOUT
CONTROLLING AND CONTRACTING
EBOLA, FEARS FUELED BY HORROR
STORIES OF WHAT IT'S LIKE.
EBOLA SURVIVOR AMBER VINSON IS
TELLING US THE REALITY.
THE DALLAS NURSE REVEALS THE
AGONY OF THE ILLNESS AND
SOMETHING ELSE THAT HURT, BEING
QUESTIONED WHEN SHE FLEW ON A
COMMERCIAL JET AFTER TREATING A
LIBERIAN MAN WITH EBOLA.
VINSON SAT DOWN WITH DON LEMON
AND HAD QUITE A CONVERSATION.
TAKE A LOOK AND A LISTEN.
>> I'M A NURSE.
I CARE.
I CARE FOR ME.
I WOULD NOT PUT MYSELF IN DANGER
FIRST, I WOULD NOT TAKE EBOLA TO
MY FAMILY AND MY BEST G
GIRLFRIENDS.
I WOULD NOT ENDANGER FAMILIES
ACROSS THE NATION POTENTIALLY
EXPOSING THEM TO ANYTHING.
I HAD NO SYMPTOMS.
THERE WAS NO WAY AT THAT TIME I
COULD NOT TRANSMIT IT.
SO THE SCIENCE OF IT, NO
SYMPTOMS, YOU CAN'T TRANSMIT IT,
SO GETTING ON THAT PLANE WAS
JUST LIKE WHOEVER SAT NEXT TO ME
GETTING ON THE PLANE.
THEY HAD NO SYMPTOMS EITHER, SO
I WOULD NOT, IT'S NEVER MY GOAL
OR INTENTION TO BRING HARM TO
ANYONE.
>> THAT REALLY AFFECTED YOU?
>> YES.
>> Reporter: WHY?
>> BECAUSE IT'S NOT ME.
ALL I DO IS CARE.
ALL I WANT DO IS HELP.
I WOULD NEVER TRY TO HURT
ANYONE.
>> Reporter: THAT HURT, IT HURTS
WHEN PEOPLE SAY THAT?
>> YES.
BECAUSE IT IS SO NOT ME.
SO FAR BEYOND WHAT, WHO I AM.
I'M ALWAYS CARING.
I'M ALWAYS, YOU  WHAT IT WAS LI
TO HAVE EBOLA.
WHAT DOES IT FEEL LIKE?
>> IT TAKES SO MUCH OUT OF YOU.
IT REALLY DOES.
IT IS VERY DRAINING, AND EVEN
NOW, WALKING A SHORT DISTANCE, I
GET SHORT OF BREATH, BUT WHEN I
WAS GOING THROUGH MY VERY ROUGH
COUPLE OF DAYS, YOU GOT TO FORCE
YOURSELF TO GET UP AND FORCING
YOURSELF TAKES A LOT OUT OF YOU,
TOO.
IT'S A STRUGGLE.
YOU'RE FIGHTING FOR YOUR LIFE.
>> Reporter: DID YOU EVER THINK
THAT YOU COULD LOSE YOUR LIFE,
THAT YOU MIGHT NOT MAKE IT?
>> I HAVE SUCH GREAT FAITH AND I
WAS READING MY BIBLE, READING
SCRIPTURES